hey youtubers is Charlie comic-con is
next week now we have confirmation on a
couple new characters let's break it
down there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video we're within one
week of getting that comic-con trailer
literally it's happening next Saturday
but the cool thing is you may have seen
the flash video I did last week where I
talked about the may be doing the
elongated man turns out now there's a
casting description that was released
for that character so it could be
misleading but here I'll read there's
three new characters that they're
casting and they'll sound very familiar
there's Clifford to vote the thinker and
I'm just reading from the casting
description here it says mail
4250 so a little bit older any ethnicity
after being caught in the particle
accelerator explosion
Clifford DeVoe became an extremely
intelligent metahuman a super genius
who's planned to fix all the PCs wrong
with humanity regular for season four
meaning that he'll be in most of the
episodes I've already done a bunch of
videos about the thinker and his
backstory so I'll link my season 4
playlist at the end of this because they
teased him at the end of season 3 you're
not there yet Savitt artis berry we knew
he was coming a while ago but it hadn't
been quite confirmed yet now it seems
like it's pretty officially confirmed
unless they're being completely
misleading which I don't think is the
case for those of you that ask how come
we don't see berry do more detective
work or do more work as a CSI because he
was really good at that before he ever
became the flash in fact the very first
episode where we ever saw Grant Gustin
his Barry Allen the episode was titled
the scientist it was more of a science
team up than it was the flash teaming up
with arrow the guy we got on video the
rest of the crew must have come in after
him actually it was only one guy I'm
sorry I'm late
but actually my train was late with a
second one the first one I did miss but
that was my calculus fault I've got this
great traffic app and he thought that he
right I'm here now that so great who the
hell are you and do your parents know
that you're here I'm Barry Allen from
the Central City Police Department I'm
with the crime scene investigation unit
so now it just seems like they're
introducing a villains it's going to
challenge Barry mentally as well as
physically so it's not going to be
somebody that he'll just try to outrun
someone that he'll punch in the face
someone who's going to push all of
Barry's skills to the limit the next
character is just called the mechanic
it's a female character says 30 to 40
any ethnicity and extremely intelligent
engineer who will design devices for
Clifford DeVoe basically Devoe's right
hand show support to vote no matter the
consequences recurring guest star that
means that they're not going to be in
every single episode but if you guys
have seen spider-man homecoming that's
basically the tinkerer to the vulture so
think of DeVoe is the vulture in this
equation the tinkerer just builds really
cool for him so this mechanic
character on the flash will probably
help build teuvos thinking cap from the
comics right now the mechanic character
sounds like it's going to be somebody
original to the TV show and not from the
comics but then the third character is
Ralph Denby the elongated man so
everybody's really excited about this
I'm hoping that this isn't false and
it's a different character because
originally on arrow remember they were
going to do Blue Beetle but then they
couldn't do that so they turned him into
the atom but the casting description was
still for Blue Beetle the reason why I
think the flash is able to do elongated
man is because that character debuted in
the flash comics he started out in flash
number 112 which was the Silver Age
Barry Allen era he was created by
carmine infantino who created most of
the flash rogues like the reverse-flash
Gorilla Grodd Captain colds all the
biggest characters you've seen on the
show the story of that first appearance
is basically flash versus elongated man
Barry thinks that elongated man has been
stealing stuff all over the city so he
tracks him down but then finds out that
it's someone else and they end up
teaming up to solve the crime the cool
thing about the elongated man is that
he's actually a detective so most of his
early stories were detective stories
where he would encourage you to help
solve the crime
he was part of the Justice League for a
little while most of you who are a
little bit older or middle-aged probably
remember him from identity crisis
because of the really controversial way
that they treated his wife sue didn't be
so I'm pretty sure 99% sure that the
flash TV show is going to completely
sidestep that issue but at the same time
a lot of you remembering that during the
flash season one his name Ralph Denby
appears on a list of people that went
missing after the particle accelerator
explosion in season 1 so he's missing
presumed dead what it sounds like
they're going to do is just say that he
got his powers during the particle
accelerator explosion the first season
the same way that the thinker did so at
some point he resurfaces starts using
his skills in the detective theory runs
into him then they start teaming up so
they say they're doing Ralph Denby
they don't say anything about doing sued
in B he might have a wife who died
during the particle accelerator
explosion and that's his tragic
backstory my wife is dead and I had
these crazy powers all because of
Harrison wells during season 1 that was
the big thing during season 1 everybody
wanted to kill Harrison wells without
knowing that he was the reverse-flash
and even more evil than you thought
before just because he ruined their
lives by blowing up most of the city so
I think this is all really good stuff in
terms of villains it'll push a different
side of the flash TV show that we
haven't seen since season 1 Barry
actually did a lot of detective work
during season 1 but during season 3 most
of that was Julian because he was in
Barry's lab so it sounds like Barry's
going to be spending more time at the
police station which i think is cool his
office is actually really cool set but
if you're not familiar with the comics
elongated man is exactly what he sounds
like it's a little bit like mr.
fantastic from Fantastic Four he can
stretch himself into any shape I've
already done a video talking a little
bit about a team-up that they had
involving a circus but the crazy thing
is that now we found out that that
circus set was actually from legends of
tomorrow the PT Barnum Billy Zane
episode so Billy Zane is guest starring
on legends of tomorrow and that's the
second episode of legends of tomorrow
they're filming it first I think so they
can get Billy Zane in the comic-con
trailer so obviously flash arrow legend
supergirl all the DC TV shows are
dropping their trailers next Saturday so
I'll do videos for all that stuff so no
worries there but a lot of you were also
asking me about the new Black Canary
costume I wasn't planning on doing a
separate video about it but the new
Black Canary the Dinah Drake version of
the character got her costume they
showed it off it looks like it's
inspired by the new 52 version of the
Black Canary costume so it makes sense
that they would go in that direction
they said that arrow is going to be
something of a reboot this season it'll
be a little bit more like the comics
they won't be doing the big flashback
story like they did in preview season so
I'll talk about that when I post my
arrow trailer video next week so a lot
of DC TV stuff happening d23 is this
weekend so that means star wars the last
Jedi Avengers infinity war is doing a
panel and there might be some new stuff
from Thor Ragnarok and the other Marvel
movies they've already been showing off
a bunch of costumes so we got our first
look at what Thanos is going to look
like an infinity war so I'll be doing
videos for all that stuff this weekend
it's going to be crazy leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Vincent up please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
brand new Rick and Morty and you can
click here for brand new flash season 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight